so I'm still collecting invoices from my
October 2nd appendectomy so far they
total about $6,500 but I'm still waiting
for what's called the facility fee which
includes the operating room the
anesthesia the valium the staples that
they used you know all of that stuff so
when I have it all I'm gonna come to you
with a full detailed accounting for my
appendectomy but I do now have the
proposed changes to my health insurance
plan if I keep the same plan going into
2020 and I think this will be really
informative because it's gonna actually
expose the disgustingly broken nature of
how our healthcare system and health
insurance system is fundamentally
organized at a base level and should
really sound the alarm as it's obviously
it's not just me who's sounding the
alarm but this will once again sound the
alarm is another data point for why the
system needs to change so I live in
Massachusetts Massachusetts considered
to be one of the better places to be
thanks to Romney care sort of precursor
to Obamacare when it comes to health
insurance very close to total health
coverage here in Massachusetts
MassHealth is a program that is very
popular for people who have it on the
basis of their income since I have my
own business
um and I exceed the income limits for a
subsidized plan or a MassHealth plan
I just buy my plan through something
called the Massachusetts health
connector I it's unsubsidized it's just
it's a market for people who are
self-employed or whose job does not
offer health insurance so I just pay for
the plan now I chose what's called a
silver plan they go Bronze Silver Gold I
think there are still platinum plans
although I'm not sure of course the
higher you go the more you pay monthly
but the less you pay when you need
things done silver for me seemed sort of
like the right balance between the
monthly premium and how much I have to
spend when I actually get care of
different kind
so in 2019 my plan costs 421 dollars per
month that's what I pay out-of-pocket so
let's dig into how my plan will change
between 2019 and 2020 I was just
notified of this if I stick with the
same
plan so for starters my premium goes
from 421 to 458 okay an extra thirty
seven dollars a month that's about a
nine percent increase in what I pay for
the premium but the plan also gets worse
in terms of what will be covered so my
annual deductible stays the same it's
two thousand dollars for my appendectomy
for example it looks like I'm going to
owe my full two thousand dollar
deductible of course in addition to the
four hundred and twenty one dollar
monthly payments that I'm making my
plans out-of-pocket maximum is going up
from sixty-five hundred dollars this
year to 81 hundred and fifty dollars in
2020 so the out-of-pocket maximum is the
most you would have to pay for all
covered services in a plan year so my
deductibles two thousand imagine that I
have three or four instances medical
events where I pay the two thousand
dollar deductible this year once I've
paid sixty-five hundred total my
insurance would cover everything next
year that limit is being raised to 80
150 okay my primary care Polk copay is
going from $30 to $50 remember my
premiums going up as well and in
addition it will cover less my primary
care copay going from thirty to fifty
dollars my specialist copay going from
fifty to seventy dollars if I go to a
dermatologist for example or a
podiatrist as many of you know I went to
back in June that's still not resolved
by the way my Urgent Care copay you
might remember earlier in the day of my
appendicitis I went to Urgent Care I had
a fifty five dollar copay that copay
goes up to seventy next year for
bloodwork and imaging like x-rays this
year I had a $50 copay after my two
thousand dollar deductible was met next
year it's going up to $75 per instance
after my deductible is met emergency
room this year my deductible is 350 my
co-pays three hundred dollars next year
it goes up to 350 of course after the
deductible is met so I am going to be
paying if I want to keep this plan an
extra thirty seven dollars a month that
will make my yearly premium fifty five
hundred dollars
and then I still have to hit a $2,000
deductible for lots of things and to
have even higher co-pays in other areas
like primary care specialists Urgent
Care and in the emergency room I want to
go back I think I might have misstated
the 8150 annual limit is the deductible
of two thousand plus additional co-pays
and everything else it is not multiple
deductibles I may have been unclear
about that and I apologize
so this is considered good insurance in
the individual market Massachusetts is
considered a good place to be this is
insane the system has to change and
we're going to go into this in more
detail when I spell out the appendectomy
costs that I incurred last month but
part of what makes this not work part of
what makes this system the wrong one is
that there is completely inelastic
demand for a great portion of healthcare
services using appendectomy as an
example if I don't have appendicitis my
demand for appendectomy z' is zero it's
not like with many other consumer
products well if appendectomy czar
$10,000 i don't want one if the
appendectomy is five thousand dollars I
sort of want one at $1,000 I really want
one and at $1 I would want multiple
appendectomy as I might as well take
advantage because that's such a good
deal no that's not how it works
but then once you have appendicitis your
demand is also not affected by the price
if you have appendicitis I can testify
to this if the appendectomy costs a
dollar or a thousand dollars or a
hundred thousand dollars you need it and
you need it right away and your demand
for it is not impacted by the price
compare this to for example a Tesla if a
Tesla cost a hundred thousand dollars it
might be totally out of your price range
your demand is effectively zero at fifty
thousand dollars it's a big stretch but
you're certainly more interested in it
than at a hundred thousand dollars if
the Tesla is fifteen thousand dollars
now you're very interested if the Tesla
is a hundred bucks you want to buy a
whole bunch of Tesla's potentially
that's not how health care how health
care works and that is why the system we
have is immoral and I was trying to
explain this the
other day on a live twitch stream where
we have a lot of international viewers
and they kept saying wait David you're
saying you pay for 21 a month and you
still owe 2 grand for your appendectomy
yes I pay for 21 a month for the
privilege of limiting what I owe for my
appendectomy to $2,000 rather than the
eight or nine or ten thousand dollars
that it will probably end up costing in
total this is a big piece of the
immorality of the profit the for-profit
health care system that we have we will
talk about it more upcoming and I will
get you those appendectomy figures once
I have them